las calles aparentemente banales pasan
cada año miles de millones de euros en
piedras preciosas
estamos en el barrio de los diamantes de
amberes donde la gente intenta pasar
desapercibida desde el inicio de la
guerra en ucrania round alrededor del
95% de los diamantes en bruto que entran
en la unión europea' llega aquí a esta
calle de aproximadamente un tercio son
de origen ruso
importaciones que aún no están sujetas a
las sanciones europeas este investigador
trabaja para una ong del proceso de
kimberley que lucha contra los diamantes
que financian la guerra y las
violaciones de derechos humanos desde la
invasión de ucrania se han alzado
algunas voces para investigar la red de
diamantes rusos en el punto de mira al
rosa un grupo minero que pertenece en
más de un 30% al kremlin también a
grupos en las últimas semanas ha habido
informes que han sacado a la luz
vínculos más directos de 'la rosa' que
es una empresa que contribuye
directamente al aparato militar y
nuclear ruso y estos son elementos que
deben ser examinados con más detalle de
momento la unión europea ha sancionado
la exportación de diamantes tallados a
rusia
esto es suficiente para esta activista
que pide más severidad en particular
para remediar los defectos del proceso
de kimberley
hay límites a nivel del proceso de
kimberley en particular en lo que
respecta a su definición que sólo se
refiere a los grupos rebeldes en el caso
de rusia no se trata de grupos rebeldes
que financiarían el conflicto a través
del comercio de diamantes sino de
fuerzas gubernamentales
gubernamental pero para este profesor de
economía antes cercano a la industria
del diamante las sanciones castigarían
sobre todo al sector europeo que ya se
enfrenta a una fuerte competencia de
otros países
when the distance should be sólo sería
eficaz y estas sanciones fueron
adoptadas por todos pero sabemos que
india dubai o incluso israel no adoptan
las mismas sanciones el resultado sólo
sería que europa perdería una importante
industria luces importa entiende street
the beatles
por su parte eeuu ha impuesto sanciones
a las importaciones de diamantes en
bruto procedentes de rusia pero es
difícil imaginar un boicot total ya que
una vez talladas es imposible conocer el
origen ciertas piedras